the porn star that claims she had an
affair with the president is now suing
him yeah yeah it is man it is so weird
it's almost as if we did elect a Clinton
you
[Applause]
love that people went oh as they clap oh
it's not an amusement ride here oh
there's a controversial new weapons bill
in Florida have you heard about this I'd
love people that think they're supposed
to answer no I don't think so yeah the
new list of this the new Florida weapons
ban bill the new Florida weapons bill
would allow librarians to arm themselves
yeah now in a related story talking in
Florida libraries is down 99 percent
aliy different I said Schmo foe and then
a town in Israel is building an
amusement park that some are calling the
Jewish Disneyland nice yeah the Jewish
Disneyland still has Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs except doc is the chief of
cardiology at cedars-sinai so his mother
is very proud of him
I like that one more than you that
happens sometime right sure I'm Mike I
like this one the cuts they move it
along
okay snapchat snapchat is laying off 100
employees spokesperson for the company
said it's weird it's like they were here
a second ago and then they just
disappeared doc is chief of cardiology
it's all right now we're getting it
together all right
Nickelodeon is bringing back the popular
preschoolers TV show Blue's Clues now
there's just one slight change now blue
only solves triple homicides that's the
only thing
do a little dark that one it's been
reported moving right along that's
another trick of my trade when one just
does like that you move quickly into the
next one it's been reported that
Britain's Queen Elizabeth has made over
nine million dollars betting on horse
racing yeah
when asked to comment Queen Elizabeth
said that's nothing I've won 20 million
on dogfighting I mean I'm telling you
we've done
all right yang all right and rip his
throat out come on that's how my Queen
Elizabeth talks right hey everybody on
Queen Elizabeth it's the worst
impression of the Queen Oh a chimney
sweep
you